(eerie music)
You're always so early. (snicker)
Great acceptance speech, by the way.
(footsteps, eerie music continues)
(woman clears throat)
Oh.
Thank you.
- Before we dive into today's meeting,
let's all take a moment to congratulate
Miss Nervosa on her award.
(applause)
Great, so now upstairs is very happy with the numbers,
but we are looking to increase consumers
by 20% over the next quarter.
Today's meeting is to brainstorm some
new strategies targeting the female demographic.
We're all here to pitch potential tactics,
and I expect everyone to participate in the discussion.
- Then why's SHE here?
(screams)
Okay, who's first?
The oval face shape
is the ideal face shape.
Chin fillings are a non-surgical procedure
where gel is injected into the chin
to elongate the face.
Everyone can have the ideal.
- Great work.
Next?
Oh, come on.
I know you've got something.
I can feel it in my bones.
(laughter)
(screams)
Investing in computer software technology.
Specifically, digital photograph alteration.
The industry will Photoshop women
to impossible standards,
and, in turn, those women will be fed
an unrealistic image to strive for.
- Excellent.
This is the way you ladies need to think.
Her ideas fuel all of your departments.
Next?
I've been working closely
with schizophrenia,
And I really think we're working
on some good stuff!
I mean...
You know...
And I hope you like my ideas.
I hope...
(suspenseful music)
...You're a bitch.
- Fantastic work today, ladies.
May I have a word with you?
- Of course.
I'd, um...
I'd like to put my notice in.
You're quitting?
(gasps)
You're leaving?
Did I do something?
You have the highest mortality rate
out of any of us!
I'm sorry, but I've made my decision.
I just...
I can't do it anymore.
Do what?
This.
All of it.
I can't perpetuate what I don't believe in.
Let me tell you something about this company.
There's a reason why we've been around for so long.
With, or without you,
There will be new afflictions that our
consumers will buy, if not innovate themselves.
So why not thrive off your talent?
Don't blame yourself for what the market demands,.
After all, the customer is always right.
It--It doesn't bother you?
We sell...death.
I saw one of them for the first time yesterday,
and it was...
she...was...
I do that to 24 million of them a year!
We're creating monsters...
(laughs)
You've got it all wrong...
(dramatic music coming to a crescendo)
They created us.
(eerie music playing while credits are shown)